oh really nor separately yes the Red
Hood is come to eat us to meet our Dark
Souls at the very end of the world
the final battle begins a fight between
an undead slave knight who persisted
since the age of the gods and unhindered
ash born of the cycle itself and in the
ruins of countless civilizations their
fight spills the blood of the Dark Soul
from which a new world can be born the
Ring City dlc even though it lacks a
flashy ending cutscene ends the soul
series in a beautiful way for it's
fitting that only at the end of the
world would we finally understand how it
all began in the age of ancients four
salts were found by creatures that crept
from the dark four Lord Souls
that would shape the world of course
these souls were shared for a Lord
requires subjects so Gwyn had his
royalty - which had her daughter's Nieto
had his dead and the pygmy who found the
Dark Soul fathered humanity and we
always assumed that there was only one
pygmy indeed there is only one furtive
pygmy shown in the trailer and only one
pygmy referenced as a transistor and
while it fits best that this might have
been Manus who went insane in all the
seal the furtive pygmy identity was
never really important for the furtive
pygmy was just that furtive whoever they
were whoever they became they did not
seek a name they did not seek trouble
and they certainly did not seek the
light for without light there are no
shadows like the other lords the pygmy
shared their dark soul creating a line
of pygmy royalty in the ringed City and
in the Ring City we find the first
evidence of early man descendants of
pygmies with armaments forged in the
fires of the abyss according to the
dragon head great shield the ringed
knights by command of the gods stood
amongst the ranks who set out to slay
the ancient dragons clearly they each
returned with a head of an arch dragon
as their prize yet their contributions
in the war were never lauded perhaps you
can guess why the former king of light
he did change their that ever - learn an
age as dark as Gwyn it was one thing to
have fought for a new age of fire but it
was another experience entirely to feel
this fear of losing it this fear brought
out the worst in him humanity had aided
him in this great war against the
Dragons and yet it was foreshadowed that
his age of fire would eventually fade
into an age of dark so patiently the
humans waited their turn
in dire fear of this Gwyn sealed his
fate literally a ring of fire was placed
upon the armor and weaponry of early men
and their true darkness lost forever and
one day this dark sign would appear upon
man's very flesh a feel of fire
surrounding the darkness of humanity a
brand that burns away the very soul of a
human until only a hollow is left and
eons later the very world would bear
this brand unable to move on an endless
age of fire this marked a terrible event
in human history one which may well have
tied humanity to the age of fire and an
event that may well have changed man's
very nature this was the first sin
once the Lord large burger and all that
stand from humanity and men a similar
feeling for these other roots of a world
men approaching stage of life and man
gender [ __ ] wizard
we're remaining alive some humans
remained faithful to the gods at the age
of fire and they rejected this darkness
deep within them some took pride in the
newfound undeath reveling in what it
truly meant to be branded and eventually
the new creature would even be born the
young Kindle born from the ashes of
undead who sacrificed themselves to the
flame long ago if out yet human the
earth will soon begin to swell to curse
the gods and bring ruling upon this ogre
city of dung and one day some pygmies
whisper this curse placed upon the abyss
will eventually take the gods themselves
after he conquered the arch dragons Lord
Gwyn made a habit of bestowing gifts
upon those who had aided him in his war
to see for example he awarded dukedom
and bequeathed unto him a shard of a
great soul and embraced him as a part of
the royal family to the four kings also
were fragments of a great soul
bequeathed for Gwyn recognized their
foresight and to the pygmies a great
Lord granted sovereignty over the Ring
City an isolated place at World's End
for them to live in peace however of all
the gifts he gave this one appears to
betray his prejudice towards the holders
of the Dark Soul for when we visit it's
gone the knowledge that the Ring City
was not so much a home as it was a
prison
the Forsaken rings city was walled off
by the gods to contain the pigments and
the dark solar is better left well alone
at the heart of the ring city wise
Quinn's youngest daughter locked in an
endless slumber the princess fill in all
her slumber is a deceit a lid covering
an overgrown privy a prop to keep thee
from the dark soul of thine desire
somehow the slumbering princess and/or
the egg that she holds protects the
pygmy royalty hides their Dark Souls and
perhaps even for stalls the end of the
world how well we'll get to that in a
video analyzing the princess and her
roots in the movie Angel's egg so
subscribe if you're interested in that
but ignore the house for now and simply
accept that she has this power evidenced
by the pygmies that we find when we
crush the egg and break through time
that he can imagine the ring city
revolved almost entirely around the
defense of this princess a fact that's
made abundantly clear to you as soon as
you enter these ruined nights once like
you journeying through the rings city so
that they could find the legendary Dark
Soul they were sent here on an old
King's orders but they were so soundly
crushed that they had little choice but
to swear themselves to the judicata
giant this judge capable of enslaving
the spirits of those who would threaten
the city this enslaving of those who
would threaten you Blount the city's
defenses to grow significantly over time
my keys are gone
what is over the spears of the church an
order devoted to the defense of fillion
all their last recorded member to join
was named half white who was a
missionary on a visit to the ringed City
who elected to stay behind half white
wielding the white birch bow a relic of
Allah seal surely hailed from the
ancient land of like sorceries and
considering the ring city accepted this
mission from oolacile the two cities
must have once had some sort of Alliance
and you two can stand alongside him as a
spear of the church - a divine spear the
come and honor once the stone in a time
of the Gods nearly unheard of in this
age of waning fire as a servant of the
princess and friend my dear I am honored
to have met thee this is Shira a woman
of many titles daughter of the Duke
descendant of the gods matriarch of the
church friend - Medea a dragon slaying
night s and handmaiden - princess
fillion or in no small way Shira is the
last living representative of the old
gods this place we find her is called
the dark room where she will always
remain for she took it upon herself to
imprison herself here to watch over the
undying corpse of a pygmy King long ago
a Mad King was born to the pygmy royalty
of the ringed City and Shira put him to
rest impaling the King upon her cross
spear however cross Spears were for
killing dragons and her weapon was not
suited to kill the king
and so forever entwined she took it upon
herself as an eternal duty to deliver
both the spear and the king to the dark
room where she would hold them close
until the end of time this is proof that
even primeval humanity may well have
been starting to cause problems going
wild as we know it is want to do
darkness was starting to wear upon the
Ring City it inhabitants and even its
most powerful defender Medea the dear
descendant of our dragons was raised by
the gods and since he was immortal it
made him the perfect creature to be
tasked with this eternal duty to battle
the dark
and watch over the sleeping princess
until the end of time but as the city
sank into the abyss so too did Medea
only finding release at the hands of
Shira and a nun Kindle
many of us are by the fire forsaken I
speak of dying kind and mine belogus
rise from the imbecile swamp some
claiming to have been around since the
beginning not unlike humans others
representing little more than a hunger
presumably intended to reduce the world
to nothing fear not to dark my friend
let the feast begin and so at the heart
of the Ring City we are meant to
question whether the abyss is inherently
bad but there have been many references
throughout the series of a calm and
gentle dark but so many also of an abyss
gone wild and so she lived in fear of
the dark of the things ignored at her
flesh and yet the abyss had yet to
produce any such creature the locust
preacher posits that the abyss was never
a threat or at least that it metal was
in the beginning perhaps it is the seal
of fire that casts the shadows sending
the dark into a frenzy but of all the
characters to trust can we really trust
the locusts according to their right arm
the white faced locusts were meant to
beckon men to the dark with their
sermons and since they spin the abyss in
such a positive way can we really trust
their words would you instead believe
that Gwyn was right to fear the dark was
he right to mistrust humanity to brand
them to Shepherd them to wall off the
pygmies and contain the dark soul the
answer probably lies somewhere in the
middle yes the yearning of humanity
often turns them into monsters
but any hope of a calm and gentle
darkness may well have been lost when
Gwyn marked them with the dark side and
while the ringed City has revealed that
the seal of fire was indeed Quinn's
doing the nature of undeath is still a
mystery that we have to
out for in Dark Souls 3 also remember
our dark sigils holes untouched by fire
that seep humanity and may also be
responsible for the problems of humanity
there is more dark within you then even
you now dark is the mother of all all
things were born from it
so we'll get to what exactly cursed
humanity with undeath in another video
but the fact remains hope exists in an
undead man who has endured since the age
of the gods Gale in part 2 of this video
we'll explore gales character now that
we're armed with the knowledge of the
Ring City and the origins of humanity so
click here for this video if it's out
subscribe if it isn't and I'll see you
very soon
[Music]